be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while I play video
games and talk to you about random life
stuff
eight years ago I went out and I bought
a copy of modern warfare 2 and like
anybody at the time or at least those of
us who were new I was not very good at
it I was really bad at it
and so I taken to youtube to try to
figure out ways to get better during
this time I came across youtubers that I
still watch to this day you know we're
least the ones who were so active you
know seananners touched abe chris smoove
you know these these content creators
that helped me to get better at the game
you know but I remember watching early
videos that they had created when there
was a sort of shift when they began to
create videos for a living some of them
said this what they did and some of them
didn't but the fact remained that
YouTube was another source of income and
I was enamored by that I was like that's
such a cool concept being able to do
what they love create gamer videos about
video games for a living I want to do
that one day then I started my own
YouTube channel Call of Duty never
really succeeded because the market was
so saturated but that dream never really
died and I'll sit at home one day you
know two years ago and I was like you
know I haven't really seen people who
are like explaining the publication of
histories of characters they just run
over characters and concepts and comic
books so I was like why not give that a
shot and I made a video about jason
wyngarde
and we were off to the races two years
later this channel is at almost 600,000
subscribers and it's wildly successful
and it's all because of you guys but
during this time I began to develop a
brand for myself an ID for you know and
and an identity an online identity that
was you know that was directly
correlated with comics explained or back
then it was Marvel explained and it was
something where when people saw my
videos within the first minutes or
seconds they would immediately know
that's a comment explain a Marvel
explained video and that was my intro my
intro was so unique to my channel it was
unique in a lot of ways I had people say
they loved it all the time you know this
intro so cool I love this intro' such
was amazing so on and so forth and I
loved having it there back then though
with YouTube it was all about audience
retention how long are people watching
your video well eventually I took the
intro down because of the fact that you
know within the first minute of the
video when the intro started I was
losing 40 percent of my viewer base
just right off the bat they were gone
she because they didn't want to sit
through a 30 second intro understandable
and so I took it down the vocal minority
on my channel got really really angry
about it but they were fun and so of
course you know once things changed on
YouTube I brought the intro back but
when I first created that intro when I
first established it I knew that using
music you know that wasn't world t3 by
definition
somewhere along the line would cost
copyright issues and so what did I do
I went to the creator of that song and I
said I want to buy this bought the song
from the guy got documentation to verify
it everything was cool
lo and behold I'm sitting at home on
Friday somewhere along those lines email
pops up a copyright claim has been
submitted against your channel weird so
I contact my network and they're like
we'll look into it over the course of
the next four or five days that one
email ballooned up to a hundred and
sixty a hundred and sixty claims against
my channel for a song that I own the
legal rights did leave literally the
documentation said you own this song as
work-for-hire
this gives you exclusive rights to
monetize this song my network got us
sorted out which is a cool thing we're
in the path there and the process of
sorting it out right now but what does
this mean it means that now I'm not
comfortable means it now I don't have
peace of mind anymore it means now I've
got to go through every single video
that I've ever made that has any track
in it and make sure that I've got the
documentation to back up my ownership of
that track or at least my ability to
monetize that track every single video
there's 600 and some of the videos on my
channel to give you perspective civil
war was a seventeen video series all
right that's five hours five hours of 14
minutes to be specific that's just a 17
minute the 17 video series six hundred
and seventy something videos I'm going
to go through every last one
every single one not because I'm being
told you but because it's the only way
that I can have peace of mind for those
of you guys who have never really
grasped the YouTube Content ID system
who for whatever reason have never been
able to you know adequately understand
what's going on despite the multitude of
videos to talk about it in more layman's
terms YouTube's Content ID system works
like this but let's say you were sitting
at home and somebody steals your car
they show up in a taker car you you
bought that car legally
went to a car dealership bought it they
had the title shipped to you the title
sitting in the beyond the dresser drawer
maybe you're sitting in a safe if you're
a little more wiser but you know you own
the right to that car you own that car
so many Steel's do they take it let's
say that you are safe to you know a
conscious person you've got a camera
that looks down in your car and make
sure that nothing like this happens and
you have the camera footage and you call
the cops you say hey police this guy
checked my car in the world of YouTube
that could they don't look at the
footage you don't look at the evidence
that you have to show this person stole
the car they go to the person who stole
it and they say rob says that's that's
his car is that true but the thief says
no that's my car and so the cops say
okay and then they go back to me and
they say hey this guy said that's his
car so that's there's nothing we can do
that's how YouTube Content ID works
that's it now thank God I had a network
to back me up
thank God I had a network to do to make
sure I didn't get hosed but imagine the
people who don't the ones who don't
that car would be gone forever there's
nothing they could do that's how
YouTube's Content ID works so this is
getting bad the good thing is I'm hiring
writers so they're literally going to be
transcribing nothing but video they're
gonna be transcribing all these videos
for the next however long it takes to
get them all transcribed so they're
gonna get a very good understanding of
how I talk my mannerisms how I segue
from one topic to the next so on and so
forth the bad is that this is going to
dominate my time
it's going to absolutely dominate many
times I'm not gonna have time to make
new videos to make videos on new topics
I'll make them more I can I want to make
videos about psylocke because x-men
apocalypse is coming up I want to make
videos about Archangel because x-men
apocalypse is coming up I had a video
series that I wanted to do about the
life and times of apocalypse literally
just covering the history of his
character in Marvel Comics not to
publications not going to the
publication history like I didn't
apocalypse explained providing a
chronological timeline of his character
and I can't do that now because I've got
to go back through all my videos and
make sure that I've got all the all the
documentation everything to support you
know the content I have because all it
takes is somebody to show up and say hey
youtube that's my content and you choose
like okay well sorry about your luck Rob
that's theirs
done and done that's all it takes that's
all it takes so I just walk up and say
that's mine and YouTube says okay
whatever so for those of you guys you
know who see this bear with me you know
the great thing about this is that it's
gonna give me a chance to go back and to
remaster more or less videos and I
wasn't really happy with at the time
it'll give me a chance to remaster
videos you know like like the century
you know it'll give me a chance to
remaster videos like you know whatever
else is there you know that I didn't you
know the Incredible Hulk explained or
something like that you know that I
wasn't really too fond of when I first
made it because it was back when I first
started my channel or back before it got
to my current point now where I think my
videos are more polished and more
professional you know in terms of how
they look and how they feel but I'll get
new content for you guys as soon as I
can but for right now I'm literally just
doing what I can to make sure that you
two doesn't scream me over yeah so you
guys will probably repeat videos you
know videos that we rolled I mean like
Infinity Gauntlet but like I'll have to
remake that you know I won't do Civil
War just because I've got that five hour
video for people to watch but it's I got
into YouTube to have fun I used to work
at a job where I worked all three shifts
it was a shift for a job I worked first
second and third shift and one every
week I worked all three shifts over the
course of a week and I did that every
week for over a year I got into YouTube
to get away from that I worked at that
job for ten years I never had a regular
schedule like I never had a consistent
schedule was always multiple shifts at I
work but I got into YouTube to get away
from that I did not get into YouTube to
be paranoid about my channel I did not
get into YouTube to wonder is today the
day that I'm just gonna see a hundred
and sixty claims against my video for
content that I own that's not why I got
into YouTube I don't know why to YouTube
is taking this direction I don't know
why it's in this place I don't know why
it's done this I don't know why YouTube
is so willing to you know promote
copyright infringement if you're a small
character or a small you know youtuber
but you know I guess not if Rosa you
know if if you're not part of the music
industry you know they're fine with
people infringing on your country or
your copyrighted content you know if
you're a part of the music industry if
you're some great big huge record label
well of course you know they though
advocate on your behalf but for the
small guys it's the Wild West out here
you know it's hopefully you have a good
networking you know behind you because
if you don't you're out of luck that's
just how it is so um I don't know anyway
so bear with me guys I'll get new
content out when I can but you know I
don't I don't know I don't even know if
I want to make videos on this channel
anymore anyway I'll catch you guys on
her piece